الاساليب القديمه وعقليه الحصانه لدى من
يمارسون السلطه ببساطه لا تنجح نحن امام
ازمه حقوق الانسان متكامله وبهذه الكلمات
باتت هناك لجنه امميه لتخصي الحقائق
وهدفها توثيق انتهاكات حقوق الانسان وقمع
السلطات الايرانيه للمتظرين الذين لم
يتخلوا عن الشارع لا ملاذ لهم اليه
الانترنت مقطوع لكن الصوت مسموع وصضائه قد
وصل بحسب العفو الدوليه لكن الازمه ان لكل
صوتا يسمع هناك ثمن وللاسف يدفعه
الايرانيون اعتقاله حوالي اربعه عشر الف
شخص ولم يسلم الاطفال من الامراض ايضا
قاموا عنا اهم شيء بتعبير مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي
هو الاحتجاجيه لا يقتصر لا على طبقه ولا
على جغرافيا محدده تحركات الطبقه الوسطى
والفقيره في المقدمه
احرك واقتصادي السياسي وثقافي صحيفه
اعتماد تتحدث بناء على تحليل مقاطع فيديو
وهذه المقاطع اظهرت ان طهران والمدن
الكرديه كانت اكبر بؤر للاحتجاجات خلال
اول شهرين
استخدمت الرصاصه الحي والمطاطي ضد
المتظاهرين بالاضافه لوسائل قمع اخرى وفقا
لتقارير موثقه تقدر حاصله الوفيات باكثر
من 300 شخص حتى اللحظه بينهم 40 طفلا على
الاقل وهذا امر غير مقبول تلقينا تقارير
تفيد بان الجرح في المظاهرات يخشون الذهاب
الى المستشفيات حتى لا يتم اعتقالهم
التوام الطبيه تحدثت عن تدخلات من قبل
قوات الامن اثناء علاجهم للجرحى مما تم
جمعه من تقاريرها هناك نحو 14,000 شخص
معتقلين لدى السلطات بما فيهم اطفال